hi there here we are day 23 cold day in
Vancouver broke all kinds of records
it's going to go down to ten below zero
which is very cold for Vancouver it's
not very cold for the rest of Canada but
we're not used to here we're used to
warmer weather and rain quite fitting
though because it was the first day of
activity at the Olympics I saw some
reports and news reports of the Canadian
athletes are very very happy with the
whole set up with her accommodation with
the proximity of all the events to where
they're staying the venue is spectacular
they're just absolutely tickled pink
which is nice to hear because typically
the journalists arrived first and they
do a lot of complaining we had the same
here in Vancouver for our Winter
Olympics we had a bunch of journalists
especially from the UK where they love
to do a lot of griping and complaining
and they had nothing but complaints but
in the end Vancouver had a very good
Olympics and I'm hoping that the same
will be the case at Sochi of course I
hope Canada wins a good number of medals
but even without that I just hope it's a
very good event and that a lot of people
from a lot of different countries to get
together and enjoy each other's company
in a way I'd like to be there practice
my Russian is over now getting back to
Korean yesterday I had a conversation
with a Korean tutor and I did very
poorly in my own mind at least I did
much worse than when I spoke with
joon-young and in a way I wasn't ready
for it I was I had forgotten that I even
had the discussion I was busily reading
through some articles on my computer at
Lync and I got Skyped and so I spoke for
half an hour and it sort of made me
realize that you know to get to where
you can speak well it takes time but the
way I'm gonna get there is not by
speaking more speaking every day and
I'll just repeat repeating my mistakes
granted I get a rapport with my mistakes
and I review them but I realized that
I've got a sort of redouble my efforts
in terms of my listening and reading and
so I went to and what I have to do is I
have to focus on those
finds its phrases that I have trouble
with when I speak and so speaking a
couple of times a week identify some of
those areas where I have problems so
then when I read on link I save phrases
that represent those kinds of
constructions it might be the past tense
it might be a well what in English we
would call a relative clause the house
which is on the hill kind of thing how
they say that in Korea some other things
so I go through text and I highlight
phrases and sometimes words and I tag
them I tagged them for condition like if
it's an if type phrase I call that
condition that's the tag I put on it it
might be tagged for purpose you know in
order to kind of think it might be
tagged for because or you know it's
variations of since because they're for
kind of thing like the reason why so I
tag all of these so that I can then
review them as a group and in a way I
call this mining the text so I have a
text I read through it I listen to it
and particularly now because I got these
two audiobooks from talk to me in Korean
yo News son's audiobook and particularly
huge ins re book which I'm really
enjoying and it's a lot easier there's
not that many new words so I can really
focus on the patterns and the structures
read it carefully save these patterns
and structures so that I can review them
later on so I think this mining activity
because all this is helping you to
notice and then I notice when I listen
to that same text after I've been after
have read it and mind it and highlighted
and tagged certain key phrases and so
forth then I listen to it again
I notice it so that slowly I'm making my
brain accustomed to these different
structures which are quite different
in Korean from English but even
different from Japanese and I have a
tendency to look for the Japanese
pathway and the brain makes that
Japanese connections whereas I have
conditioned my brain to make that Korean
connection so I'm doing more and more
mining so I guess today I didn't really
I had to go to the office again I I will
be doing some more you know getting out
with my iPhone and leveling up as some
people call it or doing some other
events to make it a little more
interesting and people get tired of just
looking at me here in my office but
today you know and I should point out
that in the material that I got that I
bought at talked to me in Korean I also
downloaded sort of a grammar level 3
grammar it's about 70 or 80 pages of
some grammar notes with a bunch of
explanations and that was about an hour
and a half to skim through that that's
not gonna get me too far on the other
hand if I can spend some hours mining
this content and continue to mine
content and and save phrases and words
and tag them and then review them I
think that in the long run is going to
be a better way
combining that with the continuing
ongoing listening and reading to get my
level up as I say I'm not gonna get
better at speaking just by speak I have
to enrich my knowledge my basic
vocabulary and sense of the language so
that then I go back and I didn't speak
and I speak better that's all for today
we'll see what tomorrow brings us bye
for now